- Seven minutes matters.
Seven minutes, yes Rod, we're
hacking for seven minutes.
("Six Ways" by JMKM)
Potentially.
Look at the text he sent.
Just hit him and say Gary's just looking
to get together with you.
- That's what it was, connecting?
- Yeah, we're just trying to jam together.
- Next week?
- Yep.
- Still on four tonight?
- There's four (beeping) coming
into town tomorrow morning.
- (beeping) dude?
- Yeah.
He's trying to get them, the four of them
to come through the city tomorrow.
- That's fucking nuts.
(beeping)
Yes.
- You said you may go, it's
in the middle of Cannes.
- Yes, if they can fly me in
really, really, really efficiently,
I would consider leaving
Cannes for like six hours.
- [Assistant] Something quick
for Team Gary Vee on Twitter.
Go.
- What up Team Gary Vee followers.
Number one, I see some of
you following Team Gary Vee
more than me, it hurts
my fucking feelings.
(dinging)
- [Assistant] Cool.
Thanks, G.
- You're welcome.
(writing)
- What we're doing is having core value,
more than (beeping) what we were--
- And he's okay with that?
- [Sid] I think he just
wants to talk about it.
- Talk about it, understood.
- Next Thursday evening,
you (beeping) were gonna
do drinks for an hour,
so we need to move either (beeping)
or the hour with (beeping).
- Yeah.
- Ty, if I'd known about
the Dallas event and London,
like you just want (mumbling)
scheduling, October 4th.
If Dublin's the next
week, are we moving 4 Ds?
- Alex.
You, Alex, Alex R.
- So you'll just go back to Dublin.
- I'm gangster like that.
All these Pittsburgh,
there's like a million of them, right?
There's a lot.
How many people are fucking involved
with high school football in Pittsburgh?
Can you just put 'em in a folder.
- These are the bags.
The guy who did the bags,
you promised him an Instagram shout out.
- I did?
- Yeah.
- On an Instagram Story?
- Yo Connor, think you so much for hooking
up all my guests with the bags every time.
I appreciate it.
Wanted to give you some love
'cause you fucking deserve it.
- Thank you, Gary.
- You're welcome, it's
done, it's in there.
- Can I get a set up real fast
for a mashup around
audit your inner circle?
- Around what?
- Audit your inner circle.
- Yeah.
Yo, what up guys.
One theme that I've really fucking,
people are like yo, how do
I build my self awareness,
how do I build my optimism,
how do I change my mindset?
It's the people around you.
If your best friend is Debbie Downer,
you're not gonna be as
optimistic as you can be.
If the people from your
town that you hang out with
have no fucking ambition,
you're going absolutely nowhere.
If you listen to your dad every day
about how the government sucks,
you're not gonna love life.
You've got to audit your
inner circle podcast friends,
listen to me, listen very carefully
to this mashup and these thoughts,
because this underlying tone
of who you surround yourself with
absolutely, fundamentally
changes who your are.
Period, end of story.
When I hung out with Silicon
Valley in 2005 to 2010,
I was a different dude.
When I hang out in the
agency land right now,
I'm a different dude.
When I was in college at
Mount Ida, different dude.
You're a different person.
And I'm telling you right now,
this morning podcast, or this podcast
'cause I know some of
you listen to it late,
this podcast, if I can get one of you,
one person listening to this
to dump one loser person in their circle
and add one, whoever's that smiley,
happy as fuck person at work
that you don't talk too that much
that's at a cubicle around the way,
or that awesome, you know
how everybody has like,
you have a friend, but their friend
went to college with them.
You don't really know them but
the three times you see 'em a year,
they're positive as shit,
and they're fucking do things,
surround yourself with those people.
Seek out your friend's friend
who brings positive vibes
and make them part of your world,
and cut out your homie from college
that thinks the world sucks.
Watch what that addition and
subtraction does to your life.
- [Man] That's gonna be so good.
(laughing)
- Twitter, one month
away from the NFL draft,
actually the end of this month.
Headed to Dallas.
Gonna be in the green room
with my boy, Josh Jackson,
first round pics, baby.
Looking for some brands, businesses
that want to bizz dab in the Dallas market
around the NFL draft.
Looking to do something
gnarly with VaynerSports.
Get at me, form below, hit me up.
Alright let's go.
(mellow music)